you know we're here to talk about a
really fun episode a really great
episode and we thought we should have
the writer of that great fun episode
here with us Chelsea Peretti thank you
for joining us the one the only Chelsea
Peretti Hi Chelsea see you whoa I'm just
seeing your setup it looks like CNN oh
it's the real deal incredible yeah we're
gonna breaking news
Blitzer is just about to walk in with
something it looks like a Russian
villain should appear on that screen
soon oh Chelsea I was going to tell you
this earlier the I remember the last
time I got to see you in person I was
guesting I'm Brooklyn Nine-Nine and you
guys had just done a table read and what
I hated when and I had I did two
episodes I had such a great time but uh
we didn't have any scenes together I
know yeah was that intentional my
question was did you purpose on your
part Chelsea just to avoid I asked them
to respect the restraining
was the same thing yeah absolutely I
mean I experienced the whole big cast
thing as a writer and and then I
experienced it as an actor you know
there's a deep bench in the whole Parks
and Rec Brooklyn Nine-Nine universes oh
hell yeah but what I loved when I saw
you is uh
because you know I before Parks I'd done
you know a lot of different things and
and all that stuff okay but Parks no no
I'm just saying all right anyway you
might want to see my Emmy that I have in
my house anyway which I do but it's a
daytime that's a different topic uh no
but seriously whenever I see any parks
related people it just warms my heart it
there because it was such a special
seven years and some people came and
went and it just I don't know so there
was like there's Chelsea
so weird like how intense these
entertainment experiences are and then
they feel like they'll never end
and then all of a sudden it's like
you're looking back at it like that
happened yes I mean you know in the
writer's room Greg I mean you remember
we had three meals a day together yeah
yeah we had breakfast lunch and dinner
and I was literally like this is insane
I didn't do this with my family yeah
three meals a day with my family and all
of a sudden I'm like okay I know how
so-and-so eats granola I know
I've told my wife recently that
um there were about four years of my
life where I just didn't buy groceries
because I was yeah I had 15 meals a week
with the same people I didn't need to
have food in my house because on the
weekend I wanted to get the hell out and
see other people right and then my
grocery bill shot up the Millennium
Parks ended the moment you leave a
writer's room but also yeah
um you know I was looking at some old
files to you know jog my memory to you
know get ready for our conversation and
we did these this thing the season that
you were there the seasons you were
there called um the season four Awards
and we talked and we just voted on
different topics
but we talked about our favorite
restaurant that we'd ordered from oh my
God I do want to hear all of this
because honestly like the thing I miss
the most about Parks was all the crazy
debates and tangents and you know it was
it was such a room full of smart people
you know so you were talking about
um foods and things so we had a vote on
the best individual snack you would have
which dried mango seaweed and Aisha
muhar's peanut butter toast were the top
three
um interesting and uh who would make the
most
appealing food when they come back from
the kitchen and Aisha was there again in
Dan Gore but um wow one of the defensive
but one of the great ones I mean loudest
open mouth chewing was a thing we were
just like what's what are we talking
about we did the fun stuff and now we're
gonna get some of the darker things
and Alan Yang eating dry granola not
good huh
[Applause]
you want behind the scenes people you're
getting behind the scenes yeah yeah and
I know we'll get into this episode but
Chelsea how did you come to Parks how
did that happen I want to just say one
thing back to the food we're not going
to talk about anything other than this
food yes
dried mango winning is the saddest
dried mango as a top three snack yeah I
mean that's a travesty right there well
also the dried seaweed became a thing
everybody was eating those packets of
seaweed I'm like that's violent I mean
in all three of those snacks are
actually it feels like
um
you know it would be like the favorite
snacks oh my God now I can't remember
what was the competing town that
everyone hated oh an eagle Eagleton yeah
it feels like that would be an Eagleton
top three snacks right healthy slightly
healthy slightly you know interesting
and uh and uh International like these
types of foods and now we're like here
we'd be like no it's obviously waffles
and sugar and all these things yeah just
anything anyway uh Jim how did it come
about honestly I cannot remember and
this is the thing I mean I looked at
when I wrote the script it was 2011
right so I mean that's so long ago now
it's kind of crazy yeah I also was
rereading I reread my draft and then I
reread the shooting draft and I watched
the episode because I can't even
remember like which jokes I was super
into you know it's all kind of flown the
coop
um I know Aziz encouraged me to
um
I want to say apply do you apply for a
writing job
submit submit yeah you'd have your wraps
yeah submit
and I remember coming in and meeting
with Mike I believe or maybe both Mike
and Dan I can't remember now
and meeting the writers but I can't
remember exactly you know the exact
Logistics of how it came about I
remember Aziz was doing a show at the
Orpheum and you opened for him do you
remember doing that
you killed you killed and then Aziz
comes on and I don't know half the
he's talking about because he I'm not
his uh demographic he's Jay-Z this and
Beyonce this and and but I remember the
people around me you know those very
obscure people
I'm an old sob you know no I know who
they are but he's referencing being at
this party and this rapper and it's just
you know he didn't mention Barry Manilow
he didn't mention Air Supply I mean what
am I supposed to do with that yeah but
Chelsea opened for him and I just was
blown away because I didn't know your
stand up and it was amazing and I do all
Barry Manilow jokes
he ends with everybody we made it
through the rain and then the place goes
wild and that's how she yeah it was
amazing